good luck to those of you who are
planning something yeah good luck
or a victim of something all right
switching gears here uh
many of us have probably been spending
more time sitting on the couch
since the pandemic began and a new study
found that adults
have gained roughly one and a half
pounds every month since the start of
the lockdowns last year
and it's not only adults before the
pandemic one in three children in the
u.s were considered overweight or
obese and that number may have risen
with fewer opportunities for exercise we
spoke with one massachusetts mom
who told us she grew concerned that one
of her sons was much
less active when after school and other
activities
were shut down
before the pandemic miles was going to
karate every single day he was very
active in soccer
he also has brothers and so he was
always at the playground
millions of students across the country
log on from home
when covid hit mom had to say no more
karate
no more soccer it was for safety reasons
because
everyone was so fearful so our world got
really small
more screen time started happening we
were all trapped in the house and just
said hey
we are going to have pizza because it's
literally the only release that you have
that was kind of the breaking point for
me okay
time for lunch we started making some
changes cucumbers we're introducing a
lot more vegetables
miles was a part of that conversation
around
you know having healthier food limiting
snacks
making sure we had more exercise more
movement going on
we started to kind of take a look at our
neighborhood like were we more willing
to go down to the playground
and explore that a little bit because
they needed to start moving their bodies
it's not about the shape because people
come in all different shapes
but you got to feel comfortable i want
him to move his body and breathe fresh
air
and be a happy little kid with a sparkle
back
ordering that pizza is very relatable
cbs news senior medical correspondent dr
tara narula joins us now she's also a
cardiologist at northwell health in new
york uh dr narula good morning to you
so uh let's talk about the health risks
of obesity and then get into how parents
should talk about it
there was a recent study that found that
childhood obesity went up about 2
percent
during the pandemic so in the year 2020
what does that mean for kids health
well any parent will tell you tony that
this has been so difficult
to watch all the challenges our kids
have faced and many are calling this a
pandemic summer
we know during the summer kids tend to
gain weight and this is a summer that's
gone on for over a year
so certainly we know that kids who
develop obesity are at risk for becoming
adults who have obesity and there are
health risks associated for instance
hypertension high cholesterol and
diabetes
respiratory problems like asthma and
sleep apnea acid reflux
fatty liver joint and musculoskeletal
problems and then the whole host of
psychological issues that may come up as
well depression
anxiety and low self-esteem so it really
was the perfect storm of a pandemic
exacerbating an underlying epidemic of
childhood obesity in this country
yeah so so true story from my childhood
the the first
healthy body conversation i had involved
me getting out of the pool and my
stepfather just
pinching the fat on my belly part of
that moment
didn't even occur to me i had a belly
let alone that it could get bigger no so
i don't think that it would be the
recommended way to begin that
conversation
but how do you do it because it's a
delicate one and there are a lot of ways
to put your foot wrong
absolutely and you know we have two
young daughters my husband and i my
husband's a plastic surgeon
and so we really delicately walk around
these conversations
about bodies and really what we try to
do is steer away from
image and appearance and weight and
focus on healthy living and that's what
parents really want to do it
set the patterns the foundation for a
healthy lifestyle from a young age so
the same way
that we talk to our kids about finances
and teach them about money we teach them
about values and manners we help them
with their homework and goal setting
we need to be laying down healthy habits
for exercise and diet
so that they go off to college and they
know how to make the right choices and
really also we want to pay attention to
how our kids are feeling about their
weight and so
asking them if they come to us with
questions like am i overweight
really approaching that with well what
do you feel about your weight and
how can we help you as a family and
support you in terms of making good
choices
dr narula are there certain words that
parents should avoid when talking to
their kids about weight
well certainly again you you don't want
to put your kid on a diet that is
something that has been shown that can
actually increase the risk of eating
disorders and obesity
you also don't want to restrict certain
foods or have
one child able to eat certain foods in
the house and the other child
can't and then you want to be careful
about what you talk about
with your partner in the home around
your children so avoiding comments about
your own weight or if you see people on
television
saying comments about their weight or
their image because
kids will pick up on those cues so you
have to be careful about the
conversations you have
how much daily physical activity should
children have and adults too for that
matter during this time
so children should be getting about 60
minutes a day and for adults we usually
say 150 minutes of moderate
aerobic exercise per week which is like
30 minutes a day for adults
and really what you want to do both for
kids and adults is find activities that
you enjoy
doing a variety of activities and it's
been difficult with our kids because
they've been in the house but there are
things that kids can do at home
things like setting up an obstacle
course uh playing balloon volleyball we
call it balloon bop in my house
um and then there are dance and youtube
videos and games that kids can do go
noodle has a lot of great uh
educational videos for kids on how to
stay active cosmic yoga
so there there are things that parents
can offer their kids to keep them active
in fact
the american heart association has a
great app called nfl play 60